i want to ask you though you talked a
lot about how um women and men aren't
the same we couldn't agree more there
there is a trend now of ignoring that
and the reason that people ignore it is
because it's not woke it's not woke to
say that men and women are different and
you now have you know the military you
have the police and you have the
firefighters
you have all that wokeness
kind of just saturating those spaces
where do you stand on things like women
in combat
in active combat women as police
officers women as firefighters what's
your take on all that i think it's silly
for the most part i don't think that
those dangerous jobs
i think that if we really want to be
equal like everybody says then we should
pick the best people for the position
and the best people are universally
going to be men unless again like you
want to do something like the military
where you you alter the standards for
women to get in you lower the standards
for women to get in and in that case
that's not equality so if you want
equality true equality
all the police jobs would be men
firefighters all men military all men 10
out of 10. and any
and
any kind of if you put women into the
military that's going to weaken the
military and i don't think people
understand that and it's maybe because
we're in a situation where we've been
more
there's been more peace than ever before
for the long like for a very long period
for america as a whole that we just
start to think that the world is this
utopia where everybody's all nice and
kind and china ain't committing genocide
and
i don't want to go too far
but basically what i'm saying is people
got lazy yeah people get lazy people
start to think things that are true are
not true and that's just what this is
like you can't have
women in combat in the military and i
feel weird for even saying that because
what are we doing so i'm of the opinion
like to me there needs to be one
standard for example you need to set
that sound let's talk about the police
department for example firemen you know
there needs to be one standard this
these are the qualifications to become a
firefighter you need to be able to do x
y and z i know the firefighter test is
insane you got to walk up i don't know
how many flights of stairs carrying i
don't know how much weight if there is a
woman out there who can do that who who
performs and who completes that and
passes the test great meets the
qualifications i'm all for her being a
fireman firefighter firewoman whatever
you want to call it i'm not into these
politically correct terms firefighter
whatever
if women can't do it they can't do it
you don't lower the standards because
these are industries where it becomes
dangerous right you you got a fire and
someone's at the top of a fifth floor
walk-up you're not like oh let me you
know have gender diversity that day no
you want the person who's going to get
you out of that damn building and a lot
of people is being disingenuous when it
comes to this conversation and they
don't understand that it's a man's
innate need or
it's just in our nature to protect women
so if we get in a situation where
there's a fire
and i see that my uh there's a male fire
my firefighter next to me i'm gonna
trust him to make a decision i'm not
gonna worry about him we're both gonna
go and do our job if i know that she's a
female i'm more concerned for her safety
than i would be a man so i'm going to
compromise my my original mission in
order to protect her same thing for the
military women just statistically
speaking women are more likely to have
injuries women are smaller women are
shorter women are weaker on average so
if we're going into a situation where we
need to put our best foot forward
when it comes to combat and when it
comes to strenuous physical tasks i
don't think that women would be in that
conversation manually speaking you
mentioned something about the instinct
of a man to protect uh women have you
ever seen those videos and i'm gonna
speak to new york city i come from new
york city have you ever seen those
videos that pop up from the subway where
you'll see a woman being harassed on the
subway by i don't know who and there's a
bunch of guys just sitting there
watching and they don't do anything
about it what do you think is causing
that trend particularly in cities like
new york city and los angeles among men
i think this whole teaching boys that
they're equal to women and women that
they're equal to boys doesn't help
i think that uh men by and large and
this if anybody if any man hears this
and isn't just upset i don't know what
you are then because men are just weaker
than we were before statistically
speaking when it comes to sperm count
sperm count is down to men 60
when it comes to testosterone me as a 27
year old man i'm gonna have 36 less
testosterone than a man in in
1980 is it 1989 so
i don't because they're putting uh
plastic in the ranch i don't know yeah
like you know like we're eating he's not
wrong we're overly stressed this is true
like and so for guys as a man that's
that's contributed like when you talk
about testosterone that means how you
admit how you
how you are mentally that affects how
you are
hormonally obviously it just affects how
you perform as a man it affects your
mental clarity it affects your drive to
protect and provide for women and so men
are becoming weaker and nobody's talking
about this stuff the only place you can
hear this information are channels like
in the in the manosphere so when you
want to hear stuff like this and say
okay guys that means you got to get in
the gym you can't be filled with
estrogen you got to stop eating the fast
food because they're putting ranch in
the chicken nuggets where they're
putting uh plastic in the chicken
nuggets you know what i'm saying so you
gotta start having these conversations
with young guys so that they understand
the steps that they can take to become
better and when you talk about women
getting harassed and hit and beaten and
whatever on the transit and nobody's
doing anything those are guys that are
less men than men were previously and
teaching men and women that they're both
the same and that women can defend
themselves just like men doesn't help if
you like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
[Music]